[Musique]
bonsoir petit ami au patro chevaux morts
ma passion est pourquoi nounours il me
tarde de savoir si cornichons est arrivé
à tout à leur patron ont les chaluts et
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
[Musique]
tout est ouvert
je peux rentrer c'est d'une ourse
qu'est ce que c'est que ce passe tu
laisses vergne ou encore dijon bonsoir
tu m'as fait pas le plein et un qui fait
mouly oh c'est vrai tu dors dehors oui
tu dors à la belle étoile il fait trop
chaud dans cette maison
bon ça mais vous déménagez vous aussi
nous est encore ni gens de confessions
tacos et mais jafar mousse le bel arbre
de jules guetta
[Musique]
au
déjà des bourgeons touche pas
otunnu on les appelle de petits chats
loup nicolas des chatons y en a plein
dans la forêt en ce moment juliette as
well as much as la chance mais oui l'ibu
c'est sur la nuit
[Musique]
c'est pour ça qu'on le ciaft est grande
ouverte c'est très gentil mais vous
allez vous enrhumé mais vous allez
mettre un gros cash ne fait pas tomber
nous vous la juillet tu as tu veux le
faire pour
bonsoir je tort
[Musique]
mais qu'importe tu dis revenez
au
judo
tu n'aurais pas pris le poème d'un petit
enfant par hasard
je veux bien qu'elle s'aligne au lot
elle va nous attirer des ennuis terrible
cette cheville et à halo donne moi ce
bonnet
laisse la drogue
nicolas et pimprenelle au lit et couvrez
vous chaudement
[Musique]
vanino ce
mécanicien en dormez-vous vite
et toi julietta soit sage je vais rendre
le bonnet à son propriétaire
[Musique]
ottoman
quelle petite coquine cette julietta
eh bien les enfants 6 à la nuit tombante
vous rencontrez un joli bout qui veut
vous prendre votre bonnet ou votre
casquette ou qui essaient de vous tirer
l'oreille n'ayez pas peur ce sera
peut-être julietta acquis et ce bonnet
ohlen route pas trop il faut que je
retrouve son propriétaire bonne idée
enfants fait pour eux
[Musique]
m
oh
or
[Applaudissements]